andy dalton continues to be a member of
the cincinnati bengals there was
possible trade talk with the chicago
bears didn't happen there's been this
lingering sense maybe the patriots would
get involved they reportedly aren't
interested so he's still under contract
for one more year in cincinnati and zach
taylor coach of the bengals
uh said yesterday every option is on the
table out there we're trying to put
ourselves in the best position to make
sure we're prepared for next season and
we have the best assets we can we think
the world of andy obviously it's just
kind of a weekly process for us chris
they may have blown their window to
trade this guy i mean who's going to
take him at this point for the same
reason cam newton can't find a new home
i don't know who's standing at the front
of the line saying we must have andy
dalton and his 17 million salary in the
final year of his contract
no absolutely not now
you know they got a little wiggle room
here they don't have to trade him they
don't need to do that you know they they
with a what what does he might mike a
little over 17 million dollars as far as
a cap hit you know they certainly can
afford him and joe burrow being the
number one pick and not have to worry
about that on your foot you know your
team as far as ruining it with too much
money a lot into the quarterback
position so it's not a desperation thing
where they need to go like it's an
obvious oh they're going to get rid of
this guy yeah they're going to get rid
of this guy sometime within the next
year but i do think they can hang in
there and hang on to him and keep him on
the roster for training camp or an early
season injury or something like that uh
you know to to wait for a team to be a
little bit more desperate but you're
right i mean as it stands right now
there's not a lot of spots and i don't
think uh there there's gonna be a huge
market to
get cincinnati to bite on trading them
to get what they want as far as draft
assets or a trade that they feel
comfortable with just shipping andy
dalton out the door
yeah i agree with you completely and
look
we made the argument in the past that
the panthers screwed cam newton by
holding on to him as long as they did i
mean the bengals are holding on to andy
dalton and if they can't trade him do
they just do they cut him loose and not
pay him the 17 that's 17.5 million in
cash that they're gonna owe him this
year we know the bengals are extremely
careful with money um aren't they doing
him wrong the same way that the panthers
did cam newton wrong chris
well uh well yeah you know a little bit
i i don't think there's any doubt about
that i think it's different though a
little bit with the number one pick of
the draft and
are they
definitely taking the quarterback at
this point you know are they going to
trade out of the pick i don't think
anything that that's going to happen no
but i think it's a little different
scenario with the cam newton thing the
cam newton thing was an injury they
obviously had plans to move on that way
and you know cam newton's a little bit
more of a special entity than andy
dalton in general so yeah i mean i
understand it's not the best for andy
dawn but it's a little different
situation altogether and you know i
think there's a real case you can make
to go andy dalton's a you know he could
be our backup quarterback and within
that you know he's got a great way about
him i know he's a good guy a leader that
way to where he could help out you know
a guy like joe burrow and really teach
him how to be a pro and the nuances of
the position and how to play quarterback
in the nfl i don't know what do you
think mike i mean i don't look at it as
the same way as the cam newton situation
well look i i look at it this way you
can build into the contract protections
to prevent guys from being squatted on
in the out years of their deals you can
have major roster bonuses come due in
march you can have guaranteed payments
that vest in march so it's a two-way
street and is it right to squat on a guy
that you don't intend to keep i don't
know you but they have the right to do
it the panthers had the right to do it
with cam newton and they did it and the
bengals have the right to do it with
andy dalton and they are i just think
that it gets more and more awkward as
more and more time passes and once joe
burrow is on the team it's going to be
difficult to justify just waiting and
waiting for someone to say we'll take
andy dalton off your hands i mean really
at this point who's going to trade for
him who give me give me two teams that
would be in the mix for andy dalton i
no there's not two teams there's not
you're exactly right you know what he's
gonna be viewed at right now more than
anything yeah teams are gonna want him
to be released hopefully and then
somebody's gonna bring him in as a great
insurance policy to go all right he's
our backup quarterback and if you know
our starter gets hurt we got a guy we
can depend on and our team is not going
to fall off at all you know that's what
andy dalton's going to be relegated to
being if they just cut him loose and i'm
sure they don't want to cut him loose i
mean yeah i understand that there is
some value to the player he's got more
talent that people give him credit for
and you know if you were looking for
that bridge type quarterback he could do
that uh but even for that there's just
no spots right now in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports